[Musique]
le département de La Réunion a célébré
le nouvel an chinois ce vendredi 10
février au Palais de la source les
festivités ont débuté par les
traditionnelles danses du dragon et
danse du lion
la communauté chinoise a une place
prépondérante à la Réunion elle a marqué
l'histoire de notre territoire il était
bien évidemment important pour le
département que de célébrer ce nouvel an
chinois cette fête du lapado
et nous pensons que la cette culture
vivante va permettre au futur génération
de continuer à construire la réunion que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
une nouvelle année sur le signe du lapin
symbole d'apaisement d'équilibre et de
confiance en l'avenir c'est de l'année
du Lapin d'eau donc c'est le troisième
signe qui vient dans l'ordre
astrologique chinois c'est comme le
lapin c'est un animal très sociable très
animé très bienveillant donc on espère
que cette année nous apportera beaucoup
de tolérance et beaucoup de
bienveillance ça tombe très bien puisque
après ces trois années passées dans des
conditions sanitaires difficiles l'année
lapin l'année du lapins comme je l'ai
dit ça c'est le la fête c'est la
la bonté c'est donc c'est ça tombe très
bien pour relancer la vie tout court
divers ateliers ont été proposés lors de
la soirée comme la calligraphie chinoise
le découpage est pliage de papier ou
encore l'histoire du thé
un spectacle de danse chinoise par deux
associations est venu clôturer la
manifestation
[Musique]